teacher what do you see
I see children looking at me
children oh
it's kind of creepy
well I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report it's April 11 2023 I'm talking
slightly like Howard co-selled for some
reason we're live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and locals to any of you in this
room know who Howard Cosell is does that
name mean anything to you young children
all shaking your heads no that's
depressing don't forget guys we've got a
live post game show immediately after
the show over at
reubenreport.locals.com and we have an
IOS app and an Android app if you'd like
to join us on your mobile device the
theme for today's show and I'm very
excited for today's show it's I would
say in line with a lot of things that we
do here but we're going to whittle it
down into a beautiful Floridian piece of
art the theme today is that what is
happening here in Florida obviously is
the future and what is happening about 3
000 miles that way to my right in
California is obviously the past however
we are going to have to battle this
thing out that is what we can talk about
Trump and DeSantis and Biden and Kamala
and Newsome and the rest of the clown
show of people but the real battle the
battle that is actually happening right
now is for the direction of America and
I see two choices we can either go the
Florida Fleet Freedom route
or we can go to Cali communist route
that's it that's really what it boils
down to we've got a lot of personalities
involved a lot of different methods that
will potentially get us to either one of
those places but that is exactly what
it's all about and the Machine is really
ramping up uh the attacks on the Florida
blueprint and particularly obviously
Governor DeSantis because he's the one
that right now I would say is the
standard Bearer for that blueprint
setting people free government won't do
everything it'll occasionally make sure
they're not chopping your kids dicks off
but besides that it's going to try to
stay out of your way versus what's
happening in California where it is in
every part of everyone's life and it is
taking your money and controlling what
your kids are learning or mostly not
learning or how they're being
brainwashed might be a better way to put
it and infecting everything so that
people are fleeing one state and going
into another state so what we're going
to really be talking about is how do we
usher in this new era it's not just
political people it's cultural as I
often talk about and I thought we would
start right here in my adopted hometown
of Miami because this past weekend the
UFC you guys would know all about UFC
these guys beating the crap out of each
other and a lot of people dig it they
had a massive massive event this weekend
in Miami and Dana White Dana White is
the current president of USC former
fighter now president of the UFC Dana
White was talking about what is going on
here in Florida he was talking about
Miami specifically because there are
reasons that this stuff is all happening
and I thought it was worth sharing
the attendance tonight was 19032 sold
out highest grossing event in the arena
history
the gate was 11.9 Million
six highest grossing event in UFC
history and there's a new sheriff in
town ladies and gentlemen
it beat msg's last gate Miami beat
Madison Square Garden
last gate there was uh 11.5 and it was
the same fight so
unbelievable when you think that last
time we came here we did a gate of 446
thousand and now we just beat Madison
Square Garden so I've been saying this
all week Miami is like Miami reminds me
of LA 10 years ago this place is booming
I'm sure you felt it when you're I'm
sure a lot of you are from here but
those of you that aren't I mean every
restaurant is packed till midnight one
in the morning people out in the streets
it's just like this place is as cool and
as hot and as
incredible as ever it was it was a
really I'm glad we came here it was a
cool experience
John Morgan what does it say so when you
said at the press conference hey we'll
be coming back I mean do you think this
is like an annual type destination for
you now yeah yeah we're in we're coming
to Miami this this place is such a
different place than the last time I was
here
um obviously I'm assuming a lot of this
was built up you know during covet and
you know all the stuff that
you know went on here it's just this
this whole this place is at a whole
nother level it's incredible
oh it's gonna hold up because we're
doing the work right now to make sure
that it doesn't we have a fantastic
mayor in Miami Francis Suarez we'll get
to a couple comments from him in just a
second uh who is doing all the work to
ensure that this isn't just a flash in
the pan that all of these people who are
coming here bringing all of these
businesses all of the the new Floridians
who seemingly understand what they fled
and why they are here that we're going
to do this right over time that's what's
so beautiful about Florida so
whether you care about UFC or not
specifically is sort of irrelevant it's
awesome that the UFC can now pull off a
bigger event in Miami than it can at
Madison Square Garden MSG in New York
City right like that's pretty incredible
but what he's really talking about there
and the reason I wanted to show you that
clip is the cultural change these are
things that start changing things on the
ground and then the politics can kind of
work up from that now you can look at it
in both ways like the politicians come
in Suarez has done some really nice
things to ensure that businesses
especially a lot of tech businesses can
come here and flourish that's what
that's what the city's doing and now
it's absolutely true every restaurant in
this town is packed all the time the
stores are packed all the time the
grocery stores are packed all the time
uh the the things that we're struggling
with are all functions of success house
prices are high because there's so much
competition right that is legit it can
be hard actually to uh to find a dentist
or a optometrist or whatever it might be
who's taking new clients because they
are inundated but we will get more and
more people will keep building the
metropolitan area of Miami we'll keep
expanding and we'll keep doing it right
so the reason I'm showing you this again
is not because you have to care about
UFC
but it's culturally important and when
people are saying hey I will move down
there that this place is like LA 10
years ago
something because L.A ain't like LA from
10 years ago I got to La 10 years ago in
2013. it was still good right there was
yes high taxes whatever with the
homelessness but now it is it is well I
always say San Francisco is the
dystopian nightmare but it's it's a
close second right it's doing that thing
there's nothing cool about Hollywood
anymore there aren't people like I'm
gonna go make it in LA no you go down to
Miami and do that uh so Miami is next
Miami I would say if he's saying Miami
is what La uh was 10 years ago I would
say Miami is basically 30 years in the
future right now if America is going to
succeed what we are doing here
in the biggest city in the greatest
state in the nation is the model uh the
mayor saw that Francis Suarez who I just
mentioned he saw uh the commentary By
Dana White and he said there's a new
sheriff in town and then he had a great
tweet uh with a little bit of the
specifics now when we can talk about the
politics when you vote in the right
politicians what happens Miami safety
status updates with a 30 percent
reduction in homicides and a 58 decrease
in shootings we are making great strides
towards a safer Community for all in
Miami our resident safety is our top
priority and our commitment to reducing
crime is unwavering we will continue
doing everything we can to make Miami
the safest city in America it is
beautiful it is happening and it goes to
show guys that's these things are not
disconnected when you constantly
demonize the police and call for
defunding the police we know what
happens in those democrat-run cities but
then you have to contrast that with what
happens in the cities that they fund the
police that they back the police the
other thing is we took in I think over a
thousand cop from the NYPD someone can
check me on the actual numbers on that
and Governor DeSantis gave them bonuses
they did not want to work in New York
anymore where they're treated horribly
they're abused they they don't get the
legal backing or the backing from the
mayor whether it was de Blasio or the
new guy and what did they do they're
coming down to Florida so now we're
we're getting better people to come down
here and that also will continue that
shift the blue will get Bluer and more
destructive and look and Lawless and
unsuccessful and the red will get redder
which in essence will be successful and
flourishing 700 thank you 730 NYPD
officers came down to Florida in the
last year or so think about that think
about that these are these are the best
trained or were the best trained
officers in the nation and now we got
them in Florida where we already have a
pretty good situation when it comes to
Crime I.E not that much but let's
contrast that when when Dana White
says okay Miami reminds me of La ten
years ago well what's going on in La now
as you know La has a new mayor her name
is Mayor Karen bass she replaced Eric
Garcetti who was a far left Progressive
who was Bowing in front of BLM activists
at the height of kovid you could go out
and protest but you couldn't go to work
literally on his knees in front of these
people anyway they brought in another
far left whack job mayor Karen bass and
listen to how she's going to be dealing
with homelessness this is from about
three months ago
are you still going to allow LAPD and
sanitation officers to do these sweeps
of encampments
no we these are not sweeps at all this
is getting people to move on their own
but then after the person leaves
sanitation is absolutely going to have
to be there no question about it but
this is not coercing people this is not
ticketing people or incarcerating people
this is moving people from tents to
hotels or motels
you know it's funny guys when I've been
to hotels and I've been to a couple in
my life motels Motel Six I've been to
Best Westerns I've stayed at some nicer
places every now and again I generally
have to pay to be to go to a hotel is
that that yeah for everybody yeah that
uh you see what they're doing first off
she's saying no we're not going to move
these people of course they're moving
these people these 10 cities come up all
over La in many cases they don't move
them and then and then it becomes drug
infested and and it's medically not safe
and infectious and all that stuff right
and it's a blight on the neighborhood
and then houses prices go down all of
that stuff obviously but they will
obviously move these people but then
what do they do this is the same exact
thing that Gavin Newsom lizard person
Gavin Newsom was saying he was going to
do in San Francisco about 15 years ago
when he was at the mayor we will take
these people because it's a housing
problem it's not a uh mental health
problem or a drug problem or anything
else it's just a housing problem so we
will take these people and we will put
them in hotels and motels I really just
why you think like joking aside for just
a second like if you were to picture
just like the average homeless person of
San Francisco and L.A right so you have
to picture someone who is on drugs who
is mentally not well who's probably
screaming and fighting with people and
all we're gonna put them in the Ritz
Carlton
put them on the penthouse floor next to
Richard Gere and that chick like it's so
that was the Beverly Wilshire for those
of you paying attention pretty woman
um it's so nuts it's so completely
ridiculous but it seems right this is
what progressives are really good at oh
we will put we care about homeless
people so we will put them in hotels and
motels and then we'll give them a little
card and they can get room service above
does that help anyone get off the drugs
does it help anyone with their mental
health does it actually create a
situation where these people will not
live in those hotels or motels forever
does it get anyone off the city door or
does it just kick the can down the road
so that is the model that California has
chosen it does not end there though if
you think that one was bad L.A mayor
Karen Bess here is San Francisco
politician Phil Ting saying that San
Francisco will be safer if criminals are
not locked up we just need more
criminals around us because then well
take a look
decades we had this idea that as a state
we could be safer if we put our inmates
our offenders in the most remote
parts of the state if we could just
somehow separate them from their
communities separate them from us
separates from their loved ones from
their family members that somehow
we would be safer
and what we discovered in I think San
Quentin has proven it
that actually the exact opposite is
needed
that we need
to be surrounded by community
look if you're watching this show and
you live in San Francisco
blink twice I will try to help you okay
I can see you through the screen we've
been working on that technology for
quite some time like what are you doing
leave get out these people are upset
Phil Tang is upset that criminals live
in places called prisons that you'd like
to be far away from your home he would
prefer that they'd be embedded in your
community they should be around you and
somehow you will be safer these people
are insane they are never going to stop
you really need to understand that guys
this is this is a uh I would say a
difficult conclusion to come to but it's
a true one nonetheless these people will
never stop whether it's drag queen Story
Hour or putting criminals in your
backyard or teaching your child that
he's racist because he's white they will
never stop we have to separate from them
we have to mock them and the rest of it
but every single thing that they do
we'll put homeless people into hotels we
will take jailed people and put them in
local communities it makes everything
worse always and then you know who pays
the price good decent citizens and then
and then what happens is good decent
citizens everyone gets to their breaking
point I got to my breaking point in La I
have no doubt many of you I know how
many of you uh have moved around over
the last couple years because of covid
and everything else people get to the
breaking point and then you move
families you move businesses you move
resources and again you enrich some
places and you leave the other places
just for their scorched Earth where
where in essence nothing can grow as you
know the big story out of San Francisco
last week this is from the Washington
Free Beacon I mean this is just so
disturbing cash app Founders founder
stabbed to death in San Francisco Bob
Lee was fatally stabbed while walking
through Nancy Pelosi's District the
father of two had recently relocated to
Miami from San Francisco because of
deteriorating conditions in the city I
mean really think about that I don't
know this this one for me like actually
really hit home as someone that fled at
insanity and one of the reasons that we
fled Los Angeles was the riots were
going by our house and people doxed us
and they knew where we lived I had
people outside my house screaming at us
right
like I was in San Francisco a couple
months ago with Elon I've never in my
life I lived in New York City most of my
adult life I never didn't feel safe
there wandering around at 4am right I
never didn't on the Lower East Side
never didn't feel safe San Francisco 4
P.M in the afternoon daylight did not
feel safe this guy then moves he moves
his family and his business like he was
a huge Tech entrepreneur he moves his
family and everything to Miami to be
safe and he gets killed while visiting
the place that he left now I want to
show I'm going to show you this video
and really I this is completely not
joking and no sarcasm blah blah blah
this is extremely extremely disturbing
we debated whether we were going to show
it to you but I think this really gets
the essence of how backwards these
people are progressives do not care
about people they pretend to this is
faux virtue it's not real virtue if you
want to know the Fallout of these
policies where they let these crack
addicts out on the street and they let
the criminals out on the street and all
of those things you know what happens
actually unimaginable things this is
video it's how long is this maybe it's
20 seconds what is it seven it's seven
seconds so you can just you can
literally close your eyes if you want
but I think it's worse to just really
drive the point home that they are not
good people this is video from San
Francisco over the weekend this is a
crack addict homeless woman who gave
birth on the street seven seconds seven
seconds
okay
[Music]
guys this is third world type stuff and
it is going to continue to go in that
direction and that's what I'm talking
about about the blueprint and the
separation do you want that and do you
want that nationalized through Democrat
policies Biden Newsom whoever it might
be or do you want to separate from them
live in a place that is reflective of
your values and defend that place so I
think you know what my answer is but
these the poor conditions of these blue
cities it's not just okay now there's
crime and crack addicts having babies on
the street and homelessness and all that
what actually happens
is that it starts breaking down the
basic bonds of what a society is this is
what wokism has done incredibly well and
you have to give the devil is due right
you can't just sit there
you can't just sit there and be like oh
those wokesers those college kids like
look at them blah blah blah right when I
was talking about this stuff literally
seven years ago on the show that's the
big pushback I got Dave you're making a
mound out of a molehill there's nothing
here you know these kids are going to
get out into the real world and the real
world will will show them what's up and
though the real world folded so what
happens is not only
the stuff that we've discussed drugs
homelessness crime birth on the streets
all of those things it actually starts
leaking into public discourse and the
ability for institutions to function
which is why in so many of these blue
States and particularly blue cities blue
cities all of their institutions are
failing this one is absolutely wild you
may have seen or heard of this young
lady we've talked about her a couple
times on the show Riley Gaines she is a
a superstar swimmer who has been
outspoken against
males biological males swimming against
women and beating women right now we all
know that that is a legitimate argument
and feminists of 20 years ago would be
disgusted to know that a guy with a dick
is beating girls in swimming and the
feminists of today are applauding it
well Riley Gaines went to San Francisco
State University a couple days ago and
all she talked about was right of women
keeping men out of women's sports things
of that nature she's the most lovely
Pleasant girl you could possibly imagine
and she is an extraordinary swimmer an
extraordinary swimmer she was assaulted
by a completely violent crazed
lgbtq plus double Spirit wing wang group
and assaulted by a trans activist I
think it's a guy as a girl or just watch
the video I mean this is crazy
[Music]
I'm good
I'm coming I'm good I'm good trust me
all right
friends rights are human rights if you
mean by that your ability as an adult to
live with the same rights as everyone
else and dress as you wish and whatever
I agree with you if you mean trans
rights or human rights we get to chase
you down a hallway and assault you and
had the cops not been there rip you to
shreds and then I would slightly
disagree with that these people are
completely out of control there is not
one Democrat I could not find one not
one Democrat who was willing to condemn
that all right some Republicans did of
course imagine if that was flipped and
you had a bunch of let's say right-wing
activists chasing down you know a black
female we would be having you know riots
all over the country right now CNN would
be telling you this is white supremacy
blah blah blah you all get the double
standards okay that's just fine
um but but these people are out of
control and do you see how these things
are connected these the bad ideas
the bad ideas coupled with algorithms
coupled with a generation that is on
drugs both illegal and prescription
drugs has led to a bunch of crazy people
running down a hallway screaming at a
girl who's just saying all she's saying
is I as a girl would like to compete
against girls when it comes to swimming
do you see it but it's not going to stop
and it is being pushed by politicians
like Gavin Newsom so Gavin Newsom the
Devil Himself I believe he is an evil
lizard person he is a force of evil I
don't think he's a human being I can't
explain that fully I will continue to
flesh this Theory out I don't think he's
human I don't think he's of human I
don't think he's a robot necessarily and
I do think he's part lizard person but I
think there is I think he has been sent
here maybe this is a little bit of post
Passover Easter I'm thinking about Good
and Evil and things of that nature
anyway Gavin Newsom uh spent a couple
days here in Florida and you know here
in Florida we love uh reptiles we do we
love our iguanas we love our geckos we
even love our snakes what we don't like
are lizard people uh and here is lizard
person Gavin Newsom here's one of his
tweets from his visit to Florida and
look at the way they take those pictures
like he's such he loves books met with
some Librarians today while in Florida
they shared with me the rich diverse
background of the town and what's at
stake if we ban our kids from learning
our Real History so of course he's
saying nothing there he's saying
absolutely nothing he met with
Librarians now the only book that has
been banned across Florida is the gender
queer book which literally teaches kids
how to give hand jobs so for some reason
he's Gavin Newsom is interested in
teaching people how to give kids hand
jobs that can be clipped into and sent
across the internet because it's true
he's very upset that that book's not
going to be there also the real history
thing which is complete nonsense you
have to teach about the Holocaust in
Florida you have to teach about slavery
and civil rights what we did not want
was one single AP course about
African-American studies to also teach
gender queer Theory right because
Harriet Tubman was not a lesbo but if
she was we would teach it
Connor's eyebrow went like this what she
wasn't
um anyway this guy is just terrible he
is a lizard person show the image we
found this image I think that's real as
far as I can tell that's a real image he
is wearing a human face as a lizard
person it has been uh taped on in a very
disturbing stretched way over him and
there are his soulless eyes and his uh
you know very very expensive veneers and
crowns uh but let's continue Gavin
Newsom uh went to the library near New
college now new college is the
University here in Florida that Governor
DeSantis has decided to actually have a
diverse set of ideas when it comes to
the people that are on the board so the
college doesn't become an infested woke
leftist indoctrination Center instead
becomes you're not going to believe this
a place of Higher Learning anyway Gavin
Newsom went to a local library and here
he is because he's such a man of the
people this guy
me
[Music]
you can just feel it like how much he
hates these people actually and it's
like what are you doing here you have
ruined everything you've ever touched
except that you've become worth
something around 20 million is it around
20 million that he's worth and he's you
know he's got his relationship with uh
Nancy Pelosi and you know he's got his
wineries that he kept open in Cali while
he was you know shutting everybody
else's wineries down and all of the
horrible things that he's done and the
decimation of San Francisco what are you
doing here stay out of our free state
you communist devil worshiper we don't
want you here you are evil here's more
video from Gavin Newsom uh he was on the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC every single thing that he says
here about Rhonda said this is a lie
we'll get into it after enjoy
well you had Governor DeSantis signing a
bill on permanentless carry behind
closed doors
scared to death who is he scared of
scared of the people scared of the
people in Florida yeah that
overwhelmingly oppose that position but
I think the majority of NRA members you
know probably oppose that position no
background checks
no back no background none really
I mean no TR no training why would we do
that with weapons of war which is what
permitless carry means that's extreme in
the extreme that's what's happened of
course not surprising where guy doesn't
believe that a young girl
uh should have the freedom to determine
her own reproductive future it has to
Bear the child of a rapist
in the name of freedom without the
exception of rape and incest I mean
that's what we're getting from these
folks so look it sickens me in my court
thickens me
all right let's just do it Dave stay
calm stay calm Dave Life's good you live
in Florida okay you're right stay calm
everybody all right first off uh there
is a rape an incest exclusion here in
Florida we also have a 15-week ban on
abortion so you can have the abortion up
to 15 weeks there is a bill in the
Florida house right now to change it to
six weeks which would be further than I
would want it I'm actually completely
personally comfortable 12 weeks to me
would be ideal that you know but okay 15
weeks is fine but no one's been
complaining about abortion here in
Florida so he's completely lying that a
rapist could rape a girl in Florida and
that they would force you to have the go
ahead with the birth and that he cares
about this girl's autonomy when it comes
to her own body the same guy who was
forcing people to be injected with an
experimental vaccine is is complete
nonsense also that Jen saki says that
they sign this permitless carry behind
closed doors that sounds very nefarious
behind closed doors
well yes the door might have been closed
in the office that they signed it in our
door is closed here does that mean we're
up to no good well it means nothing but
it just sounds like he signed that thing
behind closed doors everyone knew what
he was about to sign he didn't go in
there and secretly do anything they were
like Governor could you sign the bill
that we've been very public about for
the last couple of months you're going
to go ahead and sign that yeah somebody
could you just close the door there's a
draft in here it's so it's just so
profoundly ridiculous and then
everything that he says about it is a
lie no uh no uh what does he say he says
no background checks
um that you these weapons of war it's
not no background checks on the guns you
lying sack of it's that once you
have permitless carry the whole idea of
permitless carry is if you legally have
the gun and you have to have a
background check to get the gun right
even here in Florida for everywhere in
Texas everywhere else you have to have a
permit to get your gun you have to have
some level of background check and
everything else okay that's number one
the idea of permitless carry is that
once you've gone through that check why
should there be another hoop to jump
over for you to carry your gun as you
see fit you've already been checked the
whole idea that oh we can just okay
you'll have to get a permit for that and
a permit for this and a permit for that
so you it's a complete lie and she just
sits there and takes the LIE it has
nothing to do with no background checks
and weapons of war and permit it's just
you have the gun it's legally yours yes
you can do what you feel uh you want to
do with it that's it uh
here's a little more from Gavin Newsom
because they're bullies the one thing
Rhonda Sanders hasn't come in every
literally think about it every single
thing this guy does
he does with intention because he's a
weak guy masquerading as if he's a
strong guy so he takes on the most
vulnerable consistently a 700 person
College he takes on he has to find
migrants in another state I mean just
think about he goes to another state to
find migrants under false pretest and
sends them to an island he decides to
have his own police force and go out and
arrest people uh early in the morning in
their underwear because they filled out
the wrong form everything this guy does
going after the lgbtq community going
after even trying to take I mean
everything this guy does has that in
common trying to humiliate try to bully
other people and this is consequential
though because if he's successful here
it will have an impact and reverberate
in other states and other institutions
and as a guy that you know runs the UC
system and the CSU Board of Trustees the
greater conveyor belt for talent a
public education Higher Learning
anywhere on the globe this is a serious
serious moment and that's why I'm here
to call it out and all of Academia
should be calling this out okay we'll go
through the lies in just a sec but let's
just be clear what's going on here right
now is that Gavin Newsom is running for
president that 100 is What's Happening
Here what they're doing is they they
want Biden to be able to be alive right
like they want his the sack that Biden
is because he Biden is the perfect thing
for this this inept inept no it's not
enough for this intentionally evil
movement of wokism and leftism and
collectivism and socialism that's
creeping through everything Biden's
perfect for it right because he's always
been in the system he'll repeat anything
usually very poorly that they put in
front of him and he's perfect for it but
they have to have a backup in case
literally he has a stroke or whatever or
he falls up the stairs or down the
stairs or whatever it might be and Gavin
Newsom clearly is that guy so when these
people tell you that they love
minorities and women and blah blah blah
they are ready to uh throw Kamala Harris
under the bus you must understand that
they know that she cannot be president
of the United States Russia big Ukraine
small like the woman's dealing with uh
serious lack of mental Acumen to say the
least so they are going to figure out a
way to have this straight white man
LeapFrog over the black woman in case
they get to emergency mode and they have
to replace Joe Biden that is fully
What's Happening Here uh that Ron
DeSantis is a bully and he's mean and
all those things he's going after a 700
person College well actually that's our
most left-wing out of control college
and he's fixing it up so that actually
is true lgbtq people he's going after
him no one can figure out why again for
some reason Gavin Newsom wants to teach
young people how to give hand jobs Ron
DeSantis doesn't seem to be that
interested in that apparently that's an
attack on the LGBT community to him the
migrant thing that he went to other
states the migrants were here and then
he moved them to Martha's Vineyard and
then the good tolerant open-minded
diversity loving leftists of Martha's
Vineyard made sure that they got out of
there within 24 hours give me a little
bit then he called him a coward right he
said he was a coward and something else
a little bit about Rhonda Sanchez's
history during his active duty service
DeSantis was deployed to Iraq as an
advisor to U.S Navy SEAL commander in
support of the seal mission in Fallujah
ramadi and the al-anbar province his
military decorations include the bronze
star medal for meritoris service and the
Iraq campaign medal the guy's been
around the block that's the point you
are a coward you you come
with a silver spoon in your mouth you
have destroyed the state that you live
in that you dare even show up here but
anyway I'm telling you all of this
because I know everyone seems to think I
would say that the the mainstream
thought right now is that because of uh
what happened to Trump over the last two
weeks this ridiculous absolute sham
indictment out of New York that somehow
Trump is now the front runner again but
I'm telling you it's just not right it's
just not right because nobody's
attacking Trump everybody on every side
of everything is attacking DeSantis the
entire way through even though the guy
has not even announced there was a post
on Truth social by Trump that clay
Travis you guys know Clay Travis my
buddy from outkick.com commented on
let's pull that up for just a sec uh
clay wrote Donald Trump hints he might
pick Ron DeSantis as his VP if DeSantis
doesn't run for president at least
that's the way I'm reading it and what
Trump wrote was and this is this is just
a day ago Ron DeSantis is a young man
who is not doing well again against me
in the polls to put it mildly I believe
that if he decides to run for president
which will only hurt and somewhat divide
the Republican Party he will lose the
cherished and massive Maga vote and
never be able to successfully run for
office again if he remains Governor
which is what Florida voters assumed it
would be a whole different story just
saying but who knows so the implication
there what Clay is saying is that the
just say in part is oh you'll be my VP
if you sit this one out I am telling you
guys this shows that there is blood in
the water related to Trump I know that
has a whole bunch of people angry at me
but I'm just telling you what I think
that just that remember this a week ago
Trump is out there calling him a rhino
and a globalist and all of this stuff I
had a tweet about it we'll get to in a
second and now he's basically trying to
be nice to him because I think they have
realized and I said this to Rudy
Giuliani a couple days ago at an event I
did with Patrick back David we've got a
clip for you in a moment
um and I said this to Matt Gates the
name calling is not working on Rhonda
Sanders it worked on Ted Cruz and Marco
Rubio in 2015. it really did and it
worked on Hillary Clinton but taking the
guy who was doing everything that we all
asked with your nonsensical name-calling
and all of the usual BS it's not working
so suddenly Trump is going from calling
him a rhino to saying ah maybe you could
be my VP and that I think is why
personally for me at the moment I'm kind
of over the Trump thing I'm over just
throwing at a wall just throwing
everything you can get firing it at the
wall constantly seeing what sticks and
then going with that and then realizing
oh that's not working anymore and then
throwing more you know what it just
gets all over everybody I had a
tweet about just that I said I was
retweeting Clay on that I said he was
calling him DeSantis a rhino globalist
pedophile the other day he's nervous
than he should be also nobody cares for
the these rambling diatribes anymore
they want Clarity competency and real
leadership I want to focus on that for
just a second Clarity competency
competency and real leadership I would
say it's the three C's Clarity
competency and communication let me coin
that phrase right now can we write that
down and coin that I don't know if I
have to put a little star next to it or
saying that's what people want we it's
enough of this thing we've been doing it
for a while right the Trump thing
started in 2015 I'm very thankful that
Trump ran for president I'm very
thankful for his years in office they're
certainly once again a way that I will
end up voting for it maybe to Senate
this doesn't run maybe he beat some fair
and square I'm going to vote for a
republican no matter what obviously
but I think everyone's had just about
enough of this and it's it's an
interesting moment because a week ago
he's a rhino globalist and he's a
pedophile and blah blah blah and George
Soros funds him and Paul Ryan like it's
just crap against the wall right none of
it's real
but then he saw it didn't work and this
is a rare moment you don't really see
this with Trump trump knows how to go
through one way Trump knows how to break
and just Ram through everything but
suddenly he was kind of hands off that
was his sort of apology tweet in a way
that's the closest you're going to get
from an apology to Trump because Trump
realized boy this isn't working so I
better dangle something in front of him
you don't want to piss off my base and
if you don't piss them off maybe I'll
make you a VP I just don't think there's
any way DeSantis would do it I don't
even think it's constitutionally allowed
because they're both from the same state
am I right on that yeah so there's an
issue there Florida dad on Twitter had
an interesting point that I wanted to
bring up he wrote in the past month
Trump has been to Texas for a rally and
that's it DeSantis has been to 13 states
signed school choice constitutional
carry overhauled tort reform plus more
and session is only half over work ethic
matters and is what should be expected
from a president the reason I wanted to
read that was because again again it
gets to my point of just like I think
that's just people want we've had what
people want we've had enough of the show
we want just confident leaders who will
stop the insanity from infecting
whatever we have left we want to keep
what we have left we want to build new
things build out that way
but we don't want the endless
destruction and the show and and that
you will pull out all stops to destroy
anything on your quest to power Donald
Trump I just don't think people want it
anymore uh and there is evidence
actually that DeSantis well there's
plenty of evidence that he's doing the
right thing uh but that he is modeling
that for what would potentially be a
bigger run uh here he is going off on
Alvin Bragg Alvin Bragg of course is the
D.A from New York City who has put
together this absolute sham indictment
on Trump uh and DeSantis talks about
what he has done here in Florida related
to these Soros back dies
and I'm just the only person in this
country that can stand before you and
say when we had somebody in Tampa that
was trying to pursue that agenda I
yanked him from his position he's gone
so you really need to understand that
you know we get these Soros Back The
Years and we know they are and it's not
anti-semitic to say that and George
Soros George Soros has never done
anything for the Jewish people or for
Israel or anything else the guy's a
complete dirt bag billionaire leftist
lunatic but he has placed DA's in San
Francisco we know that that guy Chessa
Boudin got recalled because it was so
bad there now they have another crazy
Lefty uh he backed George gascon who was
the former San Francisco guy who ended
up being La destroyed La he has backed
people in New York like Alvin Bragg he
backed this one guy here in Tampa the
only person to get rid of a sorospactier
which is the exact type of person that's
going after Trump in New York now
Governor Ron DeSantis right but it
continues it continues I want to show
you Byron Donalds you go you guys know
Byron Donald's I think he's a he's a
massive Republican star on the way up
had him on the show a couple times from
Southwest Florida Congressman here uh
just across the state uh he went on uh
wolf blitzer's program on uh CNN and
watch this as Byron just lays out the
nonsensical case against Trump look at
Wolf's face the whole time it's pretty
priceless
wolf even the FEC looked at this and the
FEC said there's nothing to see here the
Department of Justice looked at this
they said there's nothing to see here
last time I checked Alvin Bragg does not
sit on the FEC he's not somebody who
steeped in election law he's a local
prosecutor in Manhattan where by the way
he's actually downgraded of violent
felonies in Manhattan to the people of
Manhattan aren't as safe as they should
be in their own streets that is not even
his jurisdiction so he piles that into
this indictment which frankly doesn't
even really cite what he's talking about
except the 2016 elections and we're
supposed to sit here and take this
seriously no this is politics and it's
gross politics this is the type of thing
that the American people don't want to
see look you can have disagreements
between Republicans and Democrats I have
strong opinions of my own but to say
that you're going to shoot home some
shoe horn some phony situation into a
felony indictment or 34 film the
indictments that is a stretch that is a
kangaroo court
you can see wolf Blitz are like choking
in his vomit as he's doing that you know
to my point about Clarity competency and
communication the three C's that I have
now coining right here uh Byron
knowledge has got it too and by the way
Byron Donald's just a couple days ago he
endorsed Donald Trump
I'm cool with Byron Donald's right so
when I'm saying these things like there
there's a lot of different ways we can
all play the politics version of this
and I think we have to separate that
from the idea version of this right like
you might like one candidate for this
Byron might have his own political uh
Ambitions I don't know exactly what they
are but the point is uh we can disagree
on like the candidate and whatever but
in terms of what I want Byron Donald
just did it right and he's back in Trump
so there's there's room on the margins
here there's a little gray area that we
can all play in here but the next part
of this of course is how do we stop this
at the national level because you might
be watching this in a red State and by
the way some of the red states are
struggling with different things right
now too even Tennessee which has become
redder because of the influx there
they've got a whole situation going on
at the Capitol which I'm sure we'll
cover later in the week uh but you might
be watching this in a red State going
well you know what just I just don't
care about this crap anymore I don't
care about the federal government but it
cares about you the blue States care
about you so what can we do you
let's say we had a leader who was the
president of the United States who was
competent who offered Clarity and could
communicate that Vision what are some of
the things he might want to do so that
the government wasn't up your butt all
day long well DeSantis laid that out a
couple days ago
you have a government that's on
autopilot so they will either do massive
Omnibus spending bills which nobody
really reads or has any idea what's in
it or they will do what's called
continuing resolutions which just keeps
the government going uh whatever the
previous year's levels of Appropriations
were the problem with that is that that
they're never using that number one
constitutional power they have the power
of the purse to rein in these
administrative agencies and so you have
something like doj and FBI well if you
never hold them accountable through the
legislative process either through
through law or through through budget of
course power is going to accumulate
there you've also had kind of a Trope
that a lot of Republican presidents have
accepted over the years that doj and FBI
are quote independent of the White House
and first of all these people have guns
they can put you in jail saying they're
into dependent means they're
unaccountable no they are executive
branch agencies that report to the
elected president of the United States
and an executive elected executive
absolutely has to use Article 2 power to
hold those agencies accountable I'd
rather have the fight to try to
discipline the agencies and let the
chips fall where they may then just
allow the status quo to continue in the
direction that it has gone in
okay so I don't show you that clip to be
like to say at this great Trump horrible
but the but the proof is in the pudding
right there that that calm explanation
what did I ask for competency Clarity
and communication you're getting them
all right there what do we do about
these agencies that grow bigger and
bigger and bigger that seem to have
inordinate control and nobody watching
over them you can defund them you can
look into them it's one of the jobs that
the president has to do he even mentions
article two of the Constitution right
Trump didn't do any of that that that's
just the truth now he might be more
enraged about it now and maybe he would
go ahead and do it but the fact that
DeSantis is is offering that up right
he's throwing up the softball there
here's how you go ahead and do it and by
the way what I really liked about that
was it was totally congruent with what I
talked about with Kevin McCarthy leader
McCarthy a couple weeks ago in D.C where
I said to him well you know you guys
have these hearings there's always these
departments doing all this awful stuff
but never nothing ever comes of it and
he mentioned the power of the purse too
that they are going to start defunding
the these things and it seems fairly
obvious to me that the only way that you
can get the Department of Justice or you
can get the FBI or these these agencies
that in many ways have just gone Rogan
are spending more time looking at the
average citizen for caring about what
their kid is learning in school then I
don't know maybe a domestic terrorist or
what's going on with these radicalized
trans groups that are hunting down girls
in San Francisco or etc etc uh if you
start taking away their money
you start firing people they start
becoming a little Slimmer and trimmer
and then on the ball for what the
mission is
now you've got something and by the way
guys other politicians are seeing that
too as you know Ron DeSantis has not
announced but chip Roy oh Tripp Roy who
is thought of as as a like on the right
wing of the right wing not meaning he's
far right in any pejorative sense but
meaning he's a he's basically like a
Libertarian guy from Texas he has
already endorsed uh Governor DeSantis
and now Thomas Massey who I think is
absolutely fantastic he's he's sort of
the Congressional version of Rand Paul
like he's a full and he also happens to
be from Kentucky uh he now has gone
ahead and enter and endorsed Rhonda
Sanders I had chip and and uh Thomas on
the show Representatives Roy Massey I
should say on the show when we were in
DC together if you haven't seen that you
can check that out and it's interesting
you can just see the the Liberty loving
class of people are lining up in a
certain direction there's going to be a
political cost for it but again I just
think you have to do what's right but
what else is is the machine doing okay
it can throw all kinds of stuff the
people at MSNBC can lie all of that
stuff but remember where we started
today we started talking about the
culture piece of this the culture piece
matters so Dana White talking about the
culture that is in Miami it shows you a
bottom-up version of this thing right
like Freedom leads to good people
showing up to places people are happy
restaurants are packed economy starts
doing well that's the engine that makes
America America then we have the
top-down version of culture which is
what we get out of our corporate press
and I would completely connect our
corporate press to a place of
quote-unquote Comedy like Saturday Night
Live here's Saturday Night Live
attempting to Mock and DeSantis mocking
DeSantis mocking attack DeSantis over
Disney this weekend this is this is what
I'm told is comedy you may want to put
your head on your table right now
this week Governor Rhonda Sanchez ramped
up his war on Disney after they stopped
his attempts to control Disney World's
District here to comment is the villain
from the movie Aladdin Jafar
oh my God so this is the famous
Rockefeller Palace okay so Jafar as a
Disney character what do you think of
Ron DeSantis you mean the boy
well Michael as far as villains go the
boy's an amateur he has no Riz no spark
no drip the look is giving baby mayor
I mean he did wear those white cowboy
boots but let's be honest they wore him
well he might not look the part but are
you saying DeSantis isn't bad enough not
at all I don't get me wrong the boy is
plenty evil I mean Banning Rosa Parks in
schools I'm a dark sorcerer and even I
was like Jesus dude it's Rosa Parks
yeah now he's coming for Disney after
their stance against his don't say gay
bill
from being gay that cop
carpet you know what I mean no I really
don't
if you laughed at any of that never
watch the show again I want nothing to
do with you if you smile if your lips
moved smirk anything that's it you can't
watch anymore we're done of course it's
all nonsense right so don't say gay
drivel like all like what are these
people doing what are they doing with
their lives 30 people write that show at
least they have at least 30 writers that
spend a week to come up with that crap
but again who's the machine going after
who are they focused on they're focused
on the guy not running
DeSantis more than their focused on
Trump because as I predicted a year ago
they were going to turn to santis into
Trump I.E Hitler with the calculator
he's he's Trump but he's worse because
he knows what he's doing so what do we
have to do to squash the machine whether
it's the CNN or MSNBC nonsense or
whether it's SNL and everything else we
have to keep changing the culture so
that we can so that the culture will
allow for a new political leader who has
the right ideas to flourish it has a
little something to do with us if if we
all demand Clarity and competency and
communication well then we'll get a
political leader who might care about
those things so we have to build new
things along with that right whether
that's Tech with Rumble and locals and
everything else but you also have to do
it with culture you have to show that
Colbert and Kimmel
and the red and SNL that these are
craptastic Ventures that should be
buried forever one of the things that
I'm very proud of here in the State of
Florida is you guys know Patrick Matt
David he's got a huge podcast he's a
businessman he's done a gajillion great
things he's up in Fort Lauderdale and
they just built out because they want to
go all in on this they want to build an
alternative to Hollywood as he said to
me he's buying uh well I can't even I
don't even know if that's public
knowledge but he's doing a lot of stuff
to create a new Hollywood right here in
Florida okay so what he did last week
was the second episode of his live show
in front of about 300 people the guests
were former New York city mayor Rudy
Giuliani and I we talked Trump we talked
to Santas it was fun and silly and great
uh but it was a late night show he's
getting a liquor license there there
there was a cigar bar outside they had
people partying outside like
we don't need it from Hollywood anymore
we can rebuild it right here here's a
little snippet of the show this is from
last Thursday
again just to reiterate the reason that
I that I support the guy the way I do is
because I see what he has done to my
life and I S and I suspect that many of
you if you live in Florida are feeling
the exact same same thing and I just see
what's going on here uh relative to a
country right now that is upside down in
so many ways don't forget the guy you
know four years ago he only beat Andrew
Gillum who turned out to be a meth
addict he only beat him by 30 000 votes
that's how close Florida got to
basically being Illinois or New York or
or California at this point you know
once you factor in covid so that's one
thing so he'd have to figure out some of
the legislative stuff which you know
they've got a super majority here I
think that'll work itself out I think
the other part of this probably is you
know if you're the guy that that
from where I sit I think most people see
as the most competent public leader that
we have at this point a guy who also as
I said before the age thing he's I think
he's about 45 you know he's got three
kids he's a family man he come you know
all the think of all the people over the
last you know six years who would say
you know I I get Trump on the policy I
like the policies it's working the
economy's cooking peace in the Middle
East all that stuff I don't like the
tweets and the attitude right that was
the whole thing I don't like the Mean
Tweets well congratulations you got it
with this guy so the point is I think he
can bring over the independence I think
he can bring over the disaffected
Liberals like me like this guy uh like
probably some people in this crowd he
proved it here because he went from 30
000 votes to winning by about 1.6
million votes so I think he's the
crossover guy okay I think you get my
feelings on all of this but really why I
was showing you that is because we'll
rebuild Hollywood here
here on the east coast of Florida we'll
rebuild Tech on the west coast with
Rumble and we've got Offices here in
Miami with locals all of the things can
happen but it happens with us first it
happens with people like mayor Suarez
doing the right things to invite the
right people so that Industries start
coming here and then Industries like the
UFC start coming and that's cool with a
younger set of people who maybe don't
live and breathe Politics as the way you
or I might and then next thing you know
you've got a flourishing City and you've
got a flourishing State and the places
that they leave will continue to fail
and then if a whole bunch of us really
see that then we can go all right man we
fixed it on the ground here now let's go
for the big boy right now let's go for
the federal government and see if we can
fix that and I think my feelings are
clear on who the best person to do that
would be
that is our program for today if you
have not seen it my full interview with
Marjorie Taylor green which I think you
would get to see her in a whole new
light uh is up across platforms right
now oh and I have to mention this look
at this a fan sent me this from the
locals Community this is an 8-bit
Nintendo are we are resumed yeah there
we go 8-bit Nintendo Golden Girls
apparently I've been told it's a faux
game I haven't put it in my Nintendo yet
I do have my Nintendo setup uh it's
apparently not real but imagine if the
girls eaten mushrooms jumping on Turtles
would have been great uh I leave you
with a cold close uh this is a nice
moment that so Rudy and I you know first
off I I just love this guy you know I
lived in New York City during 9 11. I
have so much respect for this guy for
those of you that read uh don't burn
this country I devote basically half a
chapter to him when it comes to to
leadership and how leaders aren't born
they they become leaders over time and
how his life's work led him to that
incredible moment around 9 11 but he's
got a great sense of humor we were
hanging out after smoking cigars we're
gonna we're gonna do something live in
in my Miami we're going to figure that
out he's just a real he sticks by his
guns whether he's right or wrong on
everything it doesn't matter he's just
he's got a great spirit I love that New
York City attitude and everything else
anyway here's a nice little moment that
we had together and then we will do a
post game show in about 47 seconds so
yeah
can you guys Google it does she have a
dick and
the fact that I just said that in front
of Rudy Giuliani
who didn't know what a meme was before
this I lived in New York City during 9
11 like this guy is a true hero and I
apologize for even doing that I don't
know what a meme is but I know what a
dick is
[Applause]
don't worry thank you good night
oh my God
[Music]